foreign
[Music]
Jacobson from CBS Saturday morning
welcome to the dish today we're
exploring the infinite World of Italian
food from a pizzeria in New Jersey to a
pasta shop in Italy for our first course
I met up with a culinary couple who have
opened one of the most sought after
restaurants in New York City
we'll take the the sweet fennel sausage
uh one pound four chefs Angie Rito and
Scott tassinelli their labor of love
starts with hand-picked ingredients
today's from a local Italian deli we
love to use that sausage specifically
actually as the base of our bolognese
sauce so this will be this will be
perfect
back at their restaurant Don Angie that
Personal Touch has helped Elevate
Italian-American food pick up calamari
to a kind of new age Italian cuisine
this is our Italian sausage bolognese
sauce so in trying to take a dish and
make it your own
how much fun how much enjoyment do you
get from that I mean a lot that's what
that's what the whole Don Angie money
really is I think new takes on classic
type dishes familiar flavors but like
surprising I think that was the only way
to make this restaurant kind of stand
out I was lucky enough to get a sneak
peek at where the magic happens we use a
lot of cheese at the restaurant I'm just
letting you know like I really like
cheese Scott gave me a crash course in
preparing one of Don Angie's signature
dishes their pinwheel lasagna so you're
going to kind of come in and you're
going to tuck it under like this and
then you're gonna roll it really just go
for it just roll it really fast like a
burrito unlike the traditional version
the pasta is pre-sliced then baked on
its side invigorating the old standard
we kind of have an advantage because
we're Two Chefs Running a Restaurant
where if it's just one Chef right they
don't have the other person with the
same creative knowledge to kind of help
them yeah it's just always it's always a
conversation but Scott and Angie aren't
just partners in business they're also
Partners in life husband and wife and
recent first-time parents they met while
working at the same New York City
restaurant love at first sight or
friendship at first sight I think it was
love at first sight on my apartment but
I mean they say love blossomed while
traveling and played out across dinner
tables throughout Manhattan I would take
her around to all different restaurants
and then we started going to Italian
American restaurants together like red
sauce old school red sauce restaurants
yeah it's just everything about it that
you know the Nostalgia of it and so
that's where we kind of really our love
like flourished I think both have red
sauce running through their veins Angie
grew up in Cleveland working in her
grandfather's Italian bakery and
specialty store and learning traditional
recipes from her Neapolitan grandmother
food was like the centerpiece of every
family gathering always a lot of it it
my grandmother's on both sides would
just make you know copious amounts of
food for everyone like way too much than
anyone could ever consume but that's
just the way it was and food was love
yes of course Scott says food was also
love for him as a kid in New Jersey his
grandparents like Angie's also
Italian-American and Avid Cooks along
with his mom
but for Scott cooking as a career only
came after a decade in ad sales I kept
thinking like I don't want to do this
for another year let alone like another
30 years so I've always loved cooking I
always wanted to try it so I went to
Colorado school and took some classes
and fell in love with it and then just
kind of went from there
at Don Angie the duo has combined their
passion for food and for family the
inspiration has always been yes the food
that we grew up eating that we're so
passionate about but we also kind of
want to do stuff that's surprising and
unique to people like how do we kind of
make stuff that's warm and comforting
and Soulful but kind of put some little
spins here and there so it's so it's fun
for people yeah like this familiar
favorite spaghetti and meatballs but
served in a frittata I'm with you on
spaghetti and meatballs like it's so
simple and more to Della spiadini topped
with pickled garlic salsa verde there's
also the spicy baked clams Francesco we
call them that because they have a
little kick from Frank's Red Hot in
there a local pizza joint in Angie's
Hometown inspired their Italian-American
wedge salad topped with creamy herb
dressing and pepperoni and for dessert
how about pinoli cookies with rosemary
and lemon or 4. Vietnamese coffee
tiramisu
Vietnamese coffee is really delicious
it's usually made with a chicory-based
coffee and then a lot of sweetened
condensed milk so we make a
a cream filling that has sweetened
condensed milk in it and then a custard
with a sweetened condensed milk in it as
well that's phenomenal
phenomenal and thanks to their new
cookbook there is no reservation
required to get a taste of some of Don
Angie's most popular offerings why did
you want to do a cookbook we just wanted
to to share our Cuisine I guess with
like a broader audience and and bring
our Cuisine into people's homes we
really set out with this book to to make
something that was approachable for home
Cooks we wanted people to get their
hands dirty and use it and cook get red
sauce all over and they've been doing it
which is insane like every day multiple
times a day we get like notifications on
Instagram people posting pictures of the
stuff they make out of the book and it
you know it's really it's really
heartwarming it's really cool no matter
the setting it's family traditions
carried on one dish at a time people
have a great time here and a great
experience and they love the food and
that's all I could ask for I have to
pinch myself sometimes because it's it's
very special that we can sort of like
contribute to people's lives and make
them happy making them feel
welcome and comfortable and having a
wonderful meal here or or sharing some
of our recipes with them at home yeah I
think it's yeah it's a great feeling
Manhattan isn't the only place with
Incredible Italian up next a Los Angeles
Chef who's been around the world and
back home again this is the dish
Chef Zach Pollock originally visited
Italy to study the country's stunning
architecture but quickly realized his
true passion was Ford's Cuisine he
shared his culinary Journey over a meal
with our Jamie wax
fire mod six to go and 33 single
pepperoni to experience Chef Zach
Pollock's beautiful flavorful often
Whimsical take on Italian cuisine while
sitting across the table from the chef
himself hmm wow is to be in the presence
of something akin to a teenager
discovering the joy of his life that is
not the cheese stick from the mall did
you go Rancher
combined with a disciplined Artisan
studied in the skills details and
techniques of ancient cultures as when
he describes the cuisine and his pizza
focused restaurant when we opened 90 of
the menu was kind of written already by
what kinds of things a pizzeria has and
the exercise here has always been
executed as best as we possibly can use
all the techniques that we've learned
and you know bring it home and kind of
keep it an honest portrayal of what it
should be like his dishes it all comes
together perfectly when one considers
that he found his passion for cooking
while pursuing his passion for
architecture as a college student
studying abroad in Italy I got
distracted while I was there the way
Italians engage with food and wine was
unlike anything I'd ever experienced
food is not just something that is
consumed it's it's a ritual it's a part
of life it connects them to their
history it connects them to their
geographies and that was just something
that really blew my mind you say the
Florentine Central Market really pulled
you in and all of the foods and
experiences there it was so overwhelming
it probably was like a kid in a candy
store and I was just totally bowled over
and had a little apartment there and I
would buy whatever I could and bring it
back to my apartment and on a little
tiny like two burner cook whatever I
could cook do you remember the moment
where you really shifted from saying I I
don't think I'm going to be an architect
anymore I think this is going to be my
life I remember being in that little
apartment and saying this is something's
going on here and I need to at least
give it a try after a brief return to
convince his parents of the shift in his
career Focus the Los Angeles native
started a series of exhausting but
meaningful apprenticeships back in Italy
I remember starting service and then
literally and this is not hyperbole
literally the woman that was running the
station where I was dodging that night
said okay it's time to break down and I
looked up at the clock and it was like
11 45 and I was in total disbelief and
that's when I knew okay like something
about restaurant cooking that is that
you're going to find really fulfilling
I've always found it really fulfilling
you you lost yourself and lost time in
that first experience first day and
after years of diligent work in the
kitchens of respected chefs the LA boy
brought all his knowledge and creativity
back home to both honor traditional
Italian cuisine and to turn it on its
head with the elegantly appointed and
sophisticated Elemento
and his inspired take on a classic Pizza
Joint Cosa Buona it's the spot where the
restaurant is has been a pizzeria since
I think the 50s so carrying on that
tradition was really important it was at
Cosa Buona that he set up a spread for
us that was nothing short of an
architectural Masterpiece just make sure
you don't stab it with the fork no I'm
gonna lift it Italian soup dumplings a
complete reversal of tortellini and
brodo people have got to smile when this
comes to the table
it's fun yeah crispy polinta with salmon
row
yes
that's all I can say is yes to every bit
of this and texture the flavors two
chopped salads one more traditional with
salami and pepperoncini the other with
fried chickpea polenta and an emulsified
vinaigrette
his irreverently reverent Hawaiian pizza
just because there's a lot of you know
Pizza out there with pineapple that
maybe isn't good doesn't mean that pizza
and pineapple can't be friends you like
that challenge absolutely and a unique
eggplant parm that cooks overnight all
of this is really very traditional in
its construction and in its flavor
profile totally and like there there's
definitely is like you say a lot of
inspiration from maybe techniques from
other cultures at all at the end of the
day is hopefully paying homage to its
roots everything here makes cohesive
sense it seems to be
a guy having a lot of fun with his
creativity and with with both his
limitations and the fact that there are
no limits really it's funny you say that
because I actually think that I work
much better when there are limits when
there are boundaries those boundaries
would force creativity I think that's
why I kind of went from architecture
into cooking because they are both very
creative Fields but they are also
heavily Bound by
by rules right now at the end of the day
the house has to stand up if it if it
looks gorgeous but it falls down you
haven't done your job as a chef you
can't just look great certainly and it
can't even just taste great or they
might all just make candy bars it has to
it has to be nutritious it has to
nourish and after a career spent
bringing new ideas to the table Zach
Pollock is grateful that he can once
again bring diners to the tape I've
always loved you know entertaining and
and making people happy and you know
there is an ambitious program that comes
with that which is how do we bring more
of these to other parts of Los Angeles
we're looking at possible other
locations well you need to put the new
location near my house please that's all
I am very good because you've made this
person very happy today I can tell you
um
salute cheers
what would an Italian food themed
episode be without pasta or for that
matter a trip to Italy where it
originated as previously seen on CBS
Sunday Morning Seth Doan traveled to a
small town in southeast Italy where One
pasta shape tops them all
the scene could not be much more Italian
a Vespa laundry on the line and women in
the street making pasta to know which
part of Italy though just look at the
shape they're making that is if you can
see it nuncia Caputo's hands move so
quickly that we've slowed down the video
to see her forming which means little
ears it's the pasta of Puglia a region
known for olive trees distinctive homes
called truly and
which Caputo says she's been making
since she was six good thing she sees it
as more art than work
because you see this Mass transform she
told us it's magic in your hands
this pasta gleams like treasure on these
streets where a number of women make
Caputo is the fourth generation in her
family too bad there won't be a fifth
she has Sons
the men here drink beer they do not make
jorgeous
this is we've been going there you know
for the last 20 years or so and uh
buying our orchetti from her and
learning actually learning how to make
it can you make it uh are we being
recorded Elizabeth minkilly has written
books on eating and dining out in Italy
and she and her daughter Sophie offer
week in Italy Food Tours to visitors so
you'll see all the women their tables
outside
in the Region's Capital body they stop
where nuncia Caputo has set up shop or
well stage
show offers mystery and head shaking
Delight
you're used to seeing pasta made in a
pastafico inside indoors why on the
street well you know originally the
pasta that we think of as the original
pasta was dried on the street they used
the sun and the wind
says passers-by once asked her mother
who's still never far if they could buy
some pasta and a business was born
this for me is the goal of Julia the
golden yes but this is flower yes flower
yes but it's yellow and Ankara pasty
feature Michaela Fiore showed us how in
Bari selling just one size of oriquette
won't do this is a lesson small medium
medium and a half
big one we counted seven which he'd
better have in stock if he wants to keep
his customers you don't have a small
okay today don't eat really they leave
yeah you don't have the right size
do you really need all of these
different sizes of orequette yes of
course you do in all seriousness
Elizabeth minkily explains different
sizes go with different sauces how does
a type of pasta become so connected with
the region of Italy well I think it has
to do with every region every town has
their own traditions and they start out
with certain kinds of flour they start
out with certain economic conditions and
then they start and then they have the
ingredients that go with that pasta so
if the north you have more cream and
more butter and more cheese whereas in
the South it's a little bit poor so you
have more vegetables where do you
rankette on your list of pastas as a
cook
oh I'm not going to go I'm not going to
weigh in on this I love all pastas
equally from all regions
dash of diplomacy can also be a key
ingredient in a country where food means
so much
you didn't think we forgot about sir did
you up next we grab a slice in New
Jersey
there are so many ways to make a
delicious pizza but according to Dan
Ricker it all comes down to ingredients
and technique I hopped over the Hudson
to learn more
foreign
what isn't there to love about pizza
nothing
pure happiness that is the essence of
Dan Richard's new cookbook filled with
Lessons Learned creating his own pies
here at his Jersey City restaurant Raza
Pizza artisanale I wanted to be the best
bite of pizza that they ever have and
this becomes their barometer for pizza
with his recipes home Cooks can become
pizziolas this is how we launch a pizza
into a Wood-Fired oven QR codes even
lead readers to instructional videos by
Richard himself one corner and pull it
over itself and just gently Pat it in
the middle because there's only so much
you can learn by reading words this is a
very tactile experience when I was
learning pizza making and bread baking I
was reading books and I always wished
that I had a master bread Baker right
right next to me now you can saying you
need to work it a little bit more yeah
you know and then we're going to coax it
out of the dough tray I joined richer in
the rotsa kitchen for a few pointers it
all starts with the dough kneaded with a
soft touch with the amount of pressure
that you would tap somebody on the back
then stretched just so okay and then
just pull your hands apart next the
toppings just under a ladle of tomato
sauce 70 grams of fresh mozzarella and
24 pepperoni slices what happened when
it was 25. it's too much getting it into
the Wood-Fired oven is harder than it
looks
go in
[Music]
I spoke too soon
yes this please
do it yeah yes Champions that I got the
top of the oven should be a little bit
warmer but the real test is judging the
pie according to Richard's 56 Point
Pizza evaluation rubric that means when
a guest takes a bite of this
beautifully baked structurally Sound
Pizza
and the flavors of fermentation should
be real floral and complex that's really
good yeah you can crushed it
Richard's Pizza Obsession had a
Bittersweet beginning it started during
a post-college graduation trip to Italy
I tasted this food that was so fantastic
and better than any pizza or pasta that
I've ever tasted so you come back from
Italy and it's like your everything is
opened up your taste buds everything
opened up but also closing down as soon
as I got back my mom was very sick and I
remember crying on the airplane home
because I was just off this adventure
right and I knew that it wasn't
it wasn't going to end well
Robin Richard died of cancer in 2002.
Richard says he got through his grief by
channeling his mom's work ethic as he
attempted to recreate the tomato sauce
he tasted in Italy so I made batch after
batch after batch and I started visiting
farmers markets to buy the ingredients
and that's where I really
it just all clicked it's the ingredients
it really comes down to ingredients and
technique eventually richer raised
enough money to buy a failing restaurant
where he worked at perfecting pasta
before turning his attention to Pizza
but Pizza is alive it's a living
breathing thing until it's consumed
because what makes pizza pizza is that
it's bread so I started studying bread
making and learning about fermentation
so we have to understand the science in
order to create a really amazing Pizza
on a consistent basis in 2012 richer
opened ratza serving up artisanal pizza
so good it soon earned this headline in
the New York Times the best pizza in New
York is in New Jersey it was important
because it broke through the location
factor if you put me in Arizona or
Arkansas I'm gonna make Fantastic Pizza
because your location does not dictate
its merits richer made us some of that
Fantastic Pizza like the project
hazelnut with hazelnuts from Blight
resistant trees developed by his alma
mater Rutgers University I I love this
next the fungi featuring chanterelle and
Mitaki mushrooms we have a forager that
we work with he just brings us a certain
quantity of mushrooms whatever it isn't
that good oh my God the guancha is
Richard's Love Letter to Rome yeah we
sat with uh a piece of guanciale a
caliper which is a measuring device for
very specific thicknesses we cut 12
different size pieces and we got just
the right one so that the edges get a
little bit crispy but the bottom of it
stays a little pliable the perfect
saltiness too it's a journey in taste
much like the creation has been for
richer he writes this of Pizza in his
book no other food is so perfect in its
imperfections so forgiving on its way to
Mastery and the joy is in the Journey
For Me of creating whatever that piece
of learning and meeting people along the
way this is a flower Miller a wheat
grower a mushroom forager a cheese maker
we just put it together your obsessions
keep channeling to new things what's the
next Obsession after pizza or does it
stay with pizza there's always something
to learn in the process
always it's never going to be finished
until I shut this restaurant down
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson
we'll see you next time for another
helping of the dish